we are here at what might be the most
low stakes competition of all time the
geek games tread extremely low we have
five competitions two teams
whoever wins at the end of the day will
take home the geek goal before we get
these geek games started let's meet our
team for takeoff work orange from the
screen.demi show our Rudnick removing
fights and he signor Welles no are
jealous Brizzy voices its Drizzy and for
Team deepest fluid from escapist and
super fan builds trisha hershberger head
writer of honest trailers Spencer
Gilbert from movie fights Dan Merle and
from the Internet
it's Joe Bereta now let's send it down
to the host of the screen w show and a
competitor today now running to get
these games officially underway what's
going on guys Hal Rudnick here for the
first ever geek games you know we spent
so much time inside watching movies
talking about movies arguing about
movies and stuffing our faces with soda
and popcorn and it's a good idea to find
a little balance in what we eat and what
we drink and what we do that's why we've
teamed up with Mick safai to come out to
this field for some good old-fashioned
physical competition so without further
adieu let's kick off the first-ever gig
first up for our teams is the Space Jam
challenge two players from each team
will compete to score as many baskets as
possible in the time allotted but it's
never that easy on the geek games each
player will also be dressed up in a
mascot costume place in the blue team
are Spencer Gilbert and kill Baretta and
for the arch team al Rudnick and Mark
Ellis these things believe they can fly
let's find out
are you gentlemen ready you both look
very adorable let's do this in three two
one
Gilbert scores first for the blue team
this is just like a live-action Space
Jam it's just like oh right to the face
you guys have not been hanging with mr.
Cooper and it's a buzzer mark LOC use it
up for Team Orange
are you gentlemen ready Spencer mark in
there round tied 1-1 it's at the cow
Rudnick and joe bereta to decide this
event
oh wow Rudnick scores early for
clockwork orange' giving them a 2-1 lead
we're down to the last few seconds Joe
Bereta setting up the tied to fuzzy oh
and he just misses rockwork orange gets
the win celebrating their first victory
but it's far from over after one event
the orange team strikes first for an
early 1o lead we're in the hydration
station with our winners how do you feel
I feel like I need to hydrate you can't
just get armpit stains kids you got to
earn those by drinking water every day
I don't want to get cocky but
the Ric Flair chair folks they're cocky
our next competition comes deep from the
recesses of outer space it's gravity
movie trivia two contestants from each
team will be asked ten movie trivia
questions while being spun in a
centrifuge like Sandra Bullock in
gravity whoever answers the most
correctly in the least amount of time
will crawl onto the muddy banks of
victory for the blue team dan merle and
joe bereta will be competing against Hal
Rudnick and Mark Ellis for the orange
team you know this challenge is all
about brain power so it's a good thing
our contestants had a balanced breakfast
typically I'd agree but that breakfast
may come back up to haunt three two one
start the machine who played Brian in
the fats in the Furious movies Paul
Walker that is correct number two what
is the last name of Harry Potter's
friend Hermione what planet was
destroyed by the Death Star in Star Wars
a new hope Alderaan number four name
four of the seven actors to play James
Bond in a film George Lazenby Sean
Connery Roger Lord pierce brosnan number
five what's the license plate number of
the Ghostbusters car in ghostbusters Oh
lock it in yeah
starting with Tim Burton's Batman and
ending with Nolan's trilogy please list
all live-action Batman movies in
chronological order Batman Batman
Returns Batman Forever
Batman and Robin Batman Begins The Dark
Knight and the Dark Knight Rises
from the Lord of the Rings Fellowship of
the Ring how many members are in the
Fellowship Oh Oh a tough quest and I
just be guessing the number of members
in the Fellowship of the Ring
both teams seem to be having trouble
answering this question I think the
gravity may be getting to him thinking
and their brains are rolling around like
a washing machine
let's go seven seconds all right the
results of this challenge are as follows
the blue team scored a perfect 10 out of
the orange team has an official score 9
out of 10 blue team wins after two
events blue has it tied up one two one
you just won a crazy trivia contest how
do you feel crazy it's time for our next
event trial by combat two people enter
one person gets knocked down in a soft
inflatable cushion
it's a best-of-three event both teams
are ready let's go check them out this
event will be as exciting as Game of
Thrones but infinitely easier to
understand two contestants will square
off in a duel the first one to fall out
of the center ring to feel the shame of
loss and be viciously beheaded in front
of their loved ones or at least be kind
of embarrassed let's get this event
underway before the old gods and the new
first up trisha the sand snake
Hershberger versus Brizzy the red
priestess voices and the game is already
over and
they complete knockout all right round
one goes to team orange next up Spencer
the Kingslayer Gilbert taking on hell
hot pie victory blue team he weighs
bye-bye to Hal running it all comes down
to this trial by combat will be decided
by Andy Thumb Mountain signor and Dan de
Pfeiffer Moreau who will take the crown
three he is an instant kill using his
energy to celebrate when he should
probably be conserving it for the next
round your three events in and orange
grabs the lead two to one you guys just
won the joust challenge how did that
work out for you I just sort of stood
there and push the stand down did you
guys do any pregame watching Cable Guy
oh I thought you meant by oh yeah and I
should have went to medieval times this
weekend in preparation these are some
classic references folks references from
other movies in another movie how do you
feel your chances are of taking this
whole thing you know what I don't want
to get cocky but the Ric Flair will
folks they're still cocky next up is the
Academy award-winning crash the game
both teams will climb inside this ball
crash into each other and try to score
points next up is crash Ball a game
inspired by the Best Picture winner from
2005 that really doesn't hold up that
well both teams will attempt to score
point by crashing into each other moving
past their misunderstandings into the
goal deepest bluest are you ready
Clockwork Orange are you ready let's go
it's a battle of balls on the field
today and deepest bluest is defending
against and he's making ground he's
almost got it to the goal line Dan in
the really awkward position drying up to
break his GoPro and he's across the line
and our jizz wins hard wins point on in
an unorthodox way to enter the ball
despite a rough start deepest bluest
keeps clockwork thorns out of the goal
for forty-five seconds in order to win
the game deepest bluest must beat that
time and deepest bluest destroys the
competition scoring in just 13 seconds
taking the point so orange team
completed this mission in 45 seconds
however the blue team did it in 13
seconds become the winners in the movie
crash right we are tied up after four
events with each team at two points it's
a battle of both mind and speed in the
labyrinth with me now is Jarrett to
explain the rules the contestants will
be racing through the labyrinth to bring
a baby of my choosing I love you in
Zoolander from the mind of Jim Henson
comes our next event the labyrinth
labyrinth contestants from both teams
will race through a labyrinth to find
here they will then need to scour
through the maze to bring back the baby
the jerath commands the first team to
retrieve all their babies will win on my
mark
in three two one for stuff in the
labyrinth
it's Andy signor and Trisha Hershberger
both competitors racing through the maze
trying to find Jerry
and Trish's new first I require an
orange baby hot on her heels is Andy
dance magic tons oh I want a purple baby
both racers now desperately searching
amazing and Trisha is first out with the
first orange baby here's Andy he has the
first purple baby
and here comes Trisha with her second
baby she's going back to tagging her
teammate blue team adds to orange team
as one and he's back with his second
baby but in the orange team make up the
time Joe Bereta is already in the mazes
Andy runs back to tag Brizzy voices
frizzies in the maze and it looks like
Joe's having some difficulty finding his
baby Grizzlies making up a lot of time
here hello this is ground control to you
pink baby please
[Music]
it was coming out with what he thinks is
his baby your first baby you're too big
it's our twins the orange team finishes
the labyrinth and goes into the final
round with a 3-2 lead but that doesn't
matter because it's time for the crown
jewel of the geek games the event that
will decide who wins the whole thing the
geek triathlon this event is worth two
points so it's truly anyone's game this
is it the main event the big show - geek
triathlon right we just want some good
clean competition we don't want anyone
to get injured at all
our teams are tired they're stretching
out they're ready to go this one is for
all of the marbles first up is the lost
jungle maze where our competitors will
be stumbling around blind much like the
writers of the hit TV show lost in the
last few seasons next up our competitors
will be doing the Indiana Jones boulder
roll will they have to go through these
giant balls down the course wearing a
fedora the final leg of our triathlon is
the Titanic slide team members will go
up the slide and come down drench
themselves in a bucket of cold ice water
ring the bell to stop their time all
four members of each team will be
competing whichever team finishes in the
least amount of time takes on the goal
all right blue team you ready
orange you ready on my mark three two
one here we go and our first two
contenders have started the triathlon
it's Dan throws Brizzy voices oh it
already
she's trying to grab his legs which is
quite dangerous I assure you girls on
top Myrtle's on top
Myrtle's down Merle's first one down
girls losing his lead he tripped and
lost his lead
rizz B's catching up both of them
entered the Titanic slide one behind the
other they are neck and neck
Denham Brizzy finished virtually tied
Spencer Gilbert now Redick start almost
simultaneously both men climbing the
wall over the top and onto the boulder
roll now Rudnick coming from behind he's
in the ball Spencer's in the lead but
not by much all hell is breaking loose
Spencer does the ice stuff hell does the
ice tone and Andy signor and trisha
hershberger again start almost time this
is probably the hardest part of the
competition for both contestants over
the wall and into the bowler role
they're jostling for position going to
the Titanic slide and Andy dives almost
thinking of Tricia to get there first
signor is ruthless and who comes
tumbling down the slide
Tricia's right behind it is
neck-and-neck both of them have dumped
themselves and our final Paris off this
is it the very last round whoever wins
this takes it all Joe blowing through
the court Jose over the wall Marcus so
this isn't even a competition oh my
goodness Joe Bereta is making this
courses mistress as he pulls away from
Mark Ellis it's not even close folks
this is a joke crushing the orange team
and delivering blue of kick games
victory
Arcas botanist comes and the Bellas run
Ellen truck it's all over deepest
bluest you just took it home that wasn't
it she blew away man
thank you I found my Zen place which was
my happy place which happened to be this
time of my life before my dad left thank
you orange orange you just lost to the
blue team how did this happen you know
when you're blessed with superior
genetics and a better diet and a more
steady lifestyle involves less drinking
you're probably going to win
that's who won today not me so the
official results are in
the team that won it all goes to team
blue that's it folks
team deepest bluest celebrates their
victory with the shark's fin dance
inspired by LL Cool J song of the same
name and we call it a day at the
first-ever screen junkies Heat games
that's it for this year's geek games
we'll see you next year at the 2016 geek
games I'm John Bailey I'm Mike Carlson
bye bye bye bye given that he was
endowed with pure randomness making a
cloak actually he's not that much of a
challenge probably endowed with pure Oh
random okay like that did you just cop
out on me